also tonight congressional Republicans
continue to call out the bias in the
Russia investigation congressman Andy
beat Andy Biggs penned an op-ed for USA
Today with the title mr. Mueller and the
witch-hunt and joining us now that a
firm mentioned congressman Andy Biggs
joining me congressman great to see you
thanks Dave good to be with you all
right let's dive right into this the
timeline matters here in the the travel
to collect the information to bring it
back to the United States hand it off so
with the new subpoena and the subpoena
powers of Devon Nunez do we see
connecting the dots as a part of this
strategy well I think so I mean chairman
Nunez is is doing a great job by issuing
that subpoena and demanding answers and
and and we we we in Congress have to
keep ratcheting this up because we know
there's bias we know there's conflict we
know that I mean with a 10,000 emails
that got taken away from the the Trump
transition team we know that those
weren't really gone through with the
normal due process this is just one more
piece of evidence to indicate that this
mulher investigation is just kind of
spun out of control and there it's wide
spread and it's broad and this may be
the scandal of our time quite frankly
and and we've got to get to the bottom
of it so how do you connect the dots
here and obviously you have this
compendium of information the emails the
text message is and you pull this all
together but now you've got to make the
connection is that the next step because
with a lot of smoke you've got to be
able to see how the fire started
absolutely and that and that's part of
why chairman Nunez subpoenas are so
important we've got to see what's going
on over there but we have to get some of
these people back before Congress to
actually answer the questions because as
you as you may have seen they just keep
deferring and saying well the inspector
general is looking at it and we'll just
- we'll just come along after the
inspector general we need to get the
inspector general to hurry up with his
report give us the information because
what we've seen is is the Democrats have
changed their
soon completely if you recall they were
asking for Russian they're accusing a
trump of Russian collusion
now we don't hear that anymore what
we're hearing is obstruction of justice
this has got to be brought back to a
focused of investigation so we can see
whether there was collusion because what
we're seeing now is the collusion came
from the DNC and Hillary Clinton what
we're seeing is that there were actually
people at the highest level of our
government trying to manipulate the
election that's what it appears to be so
we have to connect the dots we need to
keep bringing these people in and we
have to put it together and right now
they're refusing to answer our questions
with the cover of oh this is under the
Inspector General's investigation that's
our real problem for us you know going
back to the genesis of this it began of
course the Russians we know this they
tried to interfere with elections all
around the world that said that's kind
of an established fact for many years
but this began as a counterintelligence
operation looking into Russian
interference that means that any and all
in the campaigns whoever were touched by
this should be investigated are we going
to see chairman Nunez now look into this
not just the Trump campaign the Clinton
campaign the Sanders campaign any
campaign that was out there that may
have been touched or attempted to be
influenced by the Russians is this in
other words is this going to go back to
what it really is about well right now
it's it's kind of spun out of control
and frankly the Judiciary Committee has
jurisdiction over the Department of
Justice and we should be bringing these
people in well you know we're finding
out maybe the Jill Stein's campaign was
involved somehow I mean this is really
spun far beyond what mr. Miller's
authority should have been limited to
and and we have to bring it back in we
have to be a focus and the real question
is how did the Russians impact the
election if they did let's find out and
let's take care of that but reality is
this becomes so partisan with my friends
across the aisle that that isn't what
they're even looking at anymore they're
looking at anyway to get president from
out Trump out of office that's what they
wanted
they want to deed legitimize and they
want to stain president Trump instead of
saying let's let's see what's gone on
here with how did how did mr. Muller get
so out of control
well because nobody's overseeing him how
did he get all these bias people well
because there's no vetting procedure in
place and so we have to bring that back
into control and then we can get back on
focusing on the real question which is
what did Russia do with our election and
we have a pretty good idea but that you
know this dossier is really the smoking
gun and we have to really uncover
everything we can about that a pointed
question on this congressman and
something that has not been brought up I
think and looked into it needs to be
looked into some more James Comey
whether he violated presidential
privilege leaked in the documents to the
Columbia professor and his friend and
the fact that if he did violate the law
can he be charged do you think he should
be looked into and if possible charged
for violating the law well absolutely I
think he should be looked into
I mean he took information that he had
access to unique access to may have been
privileged information and to manipulate
the appointment of robert muller as a
special counsel he leaked it to his
buddy
who with the instructions you know let's
get it into the media
hey that is that's a real problem and
that goes to the whole underlying reason
why six months ago i started saying mr.
Muller should not be the special counsel
because of what Comey did but we keep
asking the questions about that and we
keep being told the inspector general's
looking into that and we did get
commitments from director Ray and from
the Attorney General that they would
reopen that if the Inspector General
felt that that was a problem I will wait
for the inspector general's report then
congressman and see what comes out see
what action is taken by you and the
Republicans in Congress and Chairman
Nunez congressman Biggs thank you thanks
David could be with you